when the two brothers had received a
legates letters they set forth from
Accra to return to the Great Khan and
got as far as layoffs but shortly after
their arrival there they had news that
the leg 8 aforesaid was chosen Pope
taking the name of Pope Gregory of
Piacenza news which the two brothers
were very glad indeed to hear and
presently there reached them at Laius a
message from the leg 8 now the Pope
desiring them on the part of the
apostille ik c not to proceed further on
their journey but to return to him
incontinently and what shall i tell you
the king of her mania caused a galley to
be got ready for the two Ambassador
brothers and dispatched them to the Pope
at Accra and when they had been thus
honorably conducted to Accra they
proceeded to the presence of the Pope
and paid their respects to him with
humble reverence he received them with
great honor and satisfaction and gave
them his blessing he then appointed two
friars of the order of preachers to
accompany them to the Great Khan and to
do whatever might be required of them
these were unquestionably
as learning churchmen as were to be
found in the province of that day one
being called friar Nicholas of vicenza
and the other friar William of Tripoli
[Music]
he delivered to them also proper
credentials and letters in reply to the
great khans messages and gave them
authority to ordained priests and
bishops and to bestow every kind of
absolution as if given by himself
improper person sending by them also
many fine vessels of crystal as presents
a great car so when they had got all
that was needful they took leave of the
Pope receiving his benediction and the
four set out together from Accra and
went to Laius accompanied always by
Messer Nikolas his son Marco now about
the time that they reached Laius bender
kadar the Sultan of Babylon invaded her
mania with a great host of Saracens and
ravaged the country so that our end
voice ran a great peril of being taken
or slayed and when the preaching Friars
saw this they were greatly frightened
and said that go they never would so
they made over to Messer Nicholas and
Messer Maffeo all their credentials and
documents and took their leave departing
in company with the master of the temple
so the two brothers and Mark along with
them proceeded on their way and
journeying on summer and winter came at
length to the Great Khan it was then at
a certain rich and great city called
chemin food
[Music]
as to what they met on the road whether
in going or coming we shall give no
particulars at present because we are
going to tell you all these details in
regular order in the after part of this
book their journey back to the Khan
occupied a good three years and a half
owing to the bad weather and severe cold
that they encountered and let me tell
you in good sooth that when the Great
Khan heard that the masses niccolò and
Maffeo polo were on their way back he
sent people a journey of full 40 days to
meet them and on this journey as on
their former one they were honorably
entertained upon the road and supplied
with all that they required and what
shall I tell you when the two brothers
and Mark had arrived at that great city
they went to the Imperial Palace and
there they found the sovereign attended
by a great company of barons so they
bent the knee before him and paid their
respects to him with all possible
reverence then the Lord made them to
stander and treated them with great
honour
showing great pleasure at their coming
and asked many questions as to their
welfare and how they had spared they
replied that they had in Verity spared
well seeing that they found the Khan
well and safe then they presented the
credentials and letters which they had
received from the Pope which pleased him
right well and after that they produced
the oil from the sepulchre and at that
also he was very glad for he had set
great store thereby and next spying mark
who was then a young gallant he asked
who was that in their company saya said
his father masa Niccolo tis my son and
your Legion
welcome is he to quaff the Emperor and
why should I make a long story
there was great rejoicing at the court
because of their arrival and they met
with attention and honor from everybody
so there they abode at the court with
the other barons
[Applause]